hello everyone my name is Vishnu Mohan
I'm faculty here at demise and i'm here
to introduce my intern for the summer
before I I kind of get into that I do
want to start by thanking everyone who
is responsible for this internship
program it is a outstanding experience
not only for the interns who are here
with us but also for the faculty that
that are associated with them we learn
as much from you guys as you learn from
us especially in informatics because
it's so collaborative and so with that
let me introduce songy who is our intern
for our research group for the summer we
are very fortunate to have her for the
summer she's going to talk a little bit
about herself and also about the project
that she was involved in which has to do
with electronic health records and how
we can improve patient care and patient
safety specifically so without further
ado let me let me ask song to get
started here so hi everyone oh hi
everyone I'm song and today I'm here to
talk about improving patient safety
through information so a little bit
about myself I'm a senior at Oregon
State University measuring in general
science pre-pharmacy with a minor in
computer science and my mentor is dr.
Vishnu Mohan so for my presentation I'm
going to first give you a big picture of
the project the research team and my
mentor are working on and then explain
my role at the intern and my
contribution to this project so there
was a report published by the Institute
of Medicine back in 1998 which stated
that every year 44,000 to ninety eight
thousand people die due to medical
errors that could have been prevented I
love all of these medical errors we are
only focusing on the electronic health
record
related errors and there are many ways
to reduce errors and focus on errors and
we are only going to focus on these
three objectives which is developing an
EHR simulation in ICU providing training
to the user and improving the EHR
interface for those of you that don't
know epic is an electronic health record
application that's adopted by ohsu it is
also number one the number one most
adaptive software in the United States
and for our project the setting is in
the medical ICU and the participants of
our simulation our postgraduate medical
trainees which includes intern residents
and fellows our simulation method starts
with the fake patient case that we built
into the system that contains 14
problems and trapped in the case we then
provide the subjects with 10 minutes to
review the case within ethic and after
the 10 minutes 10 minutes the subjects
are required to present the patient as
if they're rounding last but not least
the subjects are given feedback on how
they use the EHR by one of our doctors
so here's an example of the eye tracking
software that we've been recording we've
been using to record the subjects I
movement across the screen this is an
example of the heat map produced by the
eye tracker the colors red yellow and
green shows us the duration the
participant is looking at the screen for
example for the medications that now
over here we can see that the subject
not only looked at the name but also
across moved across to see the specific
date the medication was administered so
for preliminary results we picked two
out of the 14 traps that were built into
the case and tested the number on the
percentage of participants who recognize
the errors during the first and second
simulation as showing these two graphs
we can see that during their second
simulation they've improved so I just
gave a big picture of the project and
now i'm going to talk about my role in
this project to get familiar with the
setting of our simulation my mentor gave
me the awesome opportunity to shadow in
the medical ICU for two days with a
fellow during my shadowing I realized
three important things number one by
nature the ICU can be very chaotic
number two all of the doctors and nurses
are constantly working with epic and
number three every patient there are
tons of data to be entered about every
patient so I'm not a clinician and this
shadowing has has been a new experience
for me and to be honest I was very
overwhelmed both I the critical care
procedures and by the complexity of the
environment after the shadowing and most
importantly I realized the that the ICU
is a fertile environment for errors
doctors are constantly faced with the
large amount of data and a short period
of time to deal with them and this is
when I realized why optimal use of the
EHR is so important after this
overwhelming feeling I found the
motivation and the purpose of this
project and with determined more than
ever to contribute to patient safety
going off of the complexity in ICU so
how do we improve the EHR interface let
me first tell you about a screen ethic
called the epic accordion report the
accordion report is a highly
configurable report that displays
documentation data flow sheet data
intake output data medication and
administration record data lab results
and other patient information the term
accordion refers to the ease with which
users can expand and condense the time
frames within the report so based on the
experience with the epic EHR the doctors
our research team realized a better way
to organize all the items within the
report based on organ system for example
for the neural report we have vital
signs medications and lab and for the
pulmonary report we have vital signs
respiratory settings medications and
labs
here's an example of what I did from the
outline provided to me by the critical
care fellow the critical care doctor
each of these items has a specific idea
epic that I had to own that are
associated with the report so my job was
to go into epic and find these IDs and
to create the organization of how to
create the new report for instance over
here we can see that temperature has the
row idea of 6 and blood pressure on the
second roll over there how to row idea 5
this basically acts as instructions for
the epic analysts at ohsu to create the
new reports on the backend of ethics
vital signs were only a small piece of
the whole report perhaps the most
challenging part of this project is
working with medication again using my
outline from the pulmonary doctor and
the help of a pharmacy implementation I
was able to generate this list of
medication and in order to do this I
first created a list of the therapeutic
classes and pulled all the medications
from each therapeutic class and
organized into a list to be implemented
as instructions to the epic analysts
along with the vital signs
so now I will explain another project
that I worked on which is building a
patient case for the simulation so in
order to create a systematic way of
testing our participants we need to
create a patient within the epic system
with five days of robust data and these
data points consist of the patient's
hourly hemodynamics medication orders
and lab this is a snapshot of a file of
what we call the cookbook in order to
create the patient into the epic EHR we
can see over here oh and this is for the
medication administration record tab of
the epic software we can see over here
for example venko which is short for
vancomycin is an IV antibiotic and my
job was to enter one gram of vancomycin
into at nine o'clock and again at 2100
along with the medication doses I also
documented the hemodynamics and notes
from doctors into the system for the
patient building a case took much longer
than I expected since this involved the
work of multiple roles multiple clinical
roles and oftentimes those clinical
roles included doctors and pharmacists
who who are on busy schedule so whenever
we run into issues we had to consult
with the doctors and this made me
realize the real reality in the clinical
informatics workflow so although this
project only contains five days of data
of the patient it took about three weeks
to complete so recalling back to the
simulation I talked about the software
called the eye tracker and this is a
unique and valuable tool used in today's
research world my third project is going
back to the eye tracking videos and
analyzing the eye tracking videos and by
doing this I used an Excel template
created by our research team and for
each of the screen the subject visited I
created in the first column I tracked
the ID that we use for the screen and
when the subject looked at that
particular screen and I also tracked
down whether they looked at specific
items across the top over there for
example we can see over here for the
metformin those views in the first four
minutes the subject did not view the
metformin dose and this will then tell
us about the pattern the user is using
when using the EHR
so what I learned the biggest thing I
learned will have to be the flow of
Informatics before coming here I never
realized how interdisciplinary
informatics is it's really a place where
data people in systems all come together
computers are such a necessity now that
more and more data points are being
being tracked into it and we need to
informatics is important in that we need
to make meaningful use of that data and
to know how to interpret the data
informatics helps form the knowledge
along with informatics I also gained
many skills such as using the ethic EHR
software in order to do this I got the
opportunity to train to go to an epic
training class with the ohsu resident
and I also gained skills using Excel and
became a proficient user as well as
learning today's a valuable tool in
today's research world called the Toby I
tracker aside from those skills I got
many opportunities to attend meetings
with healthcare practitioners who work
with epic and to troubleshoot to gather
together to troubleshoot those problems
this helped me gain inside of the
reality into the hospital workflow last
but not least I would like to thank the
research team my mentor dr. Vishnu Mohan
adriel Gorsuch who helped guide me
through projects the demise faculty
staff and my fellow intern thank
Oh any question Oh juvie for your first
project out of the three that you
mentioned what did you do when there was
more than one treatment class for a
particular drug um for if there was more
than one treatment class we we took the
therapeutic class and pick the specific
pharmaceutical class within that
therapeutic class and pulled all of the
medications out of there to generate the
list I'm curious what were the 14 traps
that the clinicians had to catch the
very good question um an example would
be we purposely built something like
over sedation and tested the subjects to
see if they they realize they found that
in the EHR case if um you know that
original IOM report was came out before
the widespread use of electronic health
records is your sense that the ICU is
now safer or less safe with with epic we
have any sense event that's a very good
question um definitely was moving from
paper to the EHR we improved a lot of
errors and we were able to reduce a lot
of errors but due to the complexity of
the EHR and more data points are stored
into it definitely there's more there's
also more room for error so I would say
there's pros and cons
anymore ask another one um so from what
it looks like you have data of wat of
like what a clinician moves from when
they look through the record is it
automatically intuitive of why they jump
from point to point when looking at
different pieces of data and the record
that's a good question and I think
because i don't have the clinical
background um my mentor would you like
to chime in on that question I mean I
think I think the challenge is to try
and figure out not just what errors are
made but why those errors are made and
one of the things that we're finding
very interesting is that the pattern of
use is very different for different
users we still don't know what the
optimal pattern of uses and that's
something that we're thinking about as
we progress with this with this grant
and with our research but their two
classes of users there's this one class
of users who seem to know exactly where
they're going and in what sequence they
want to do things then and there's
another class of users who seems to
spend more time just twittering from
screen to screen to screen to find
answers the interesting thing is that we
don't have you would think that the
purposeful user is a better user but we
don't have the numbers to prove that yet
I think it is contextual the use of the
EHR is very different than the linear
use of a paper record and I think the
way that data is presented to people is
really important in trying to figure out
the best way to use it as well as the
training that each user has so the best
way that we think we can help to make
patient care safer is to what I call
build a better mouse and build a better
mousetrap at the same time and by that I
mean improve the training that users
have and at the same time improve the
interface that users are familiar with
in order to improve both ends of the
equations so to speak any other question
okay thank you
while we're switching presenters here
I'm Dave door and the next presenter is
going to be going to be Katie cartwright
from recently from Oregon State
University actually he's graduating
Thanks going on to nursing school at at
linfield so she's been working with my
team and care management plus
specifically on a really interesting
health reform issue about high-value
elements needed to transform primary
care in order to cheat achieve the goals
of health reform so you know it's it's
been a pleasure to sort of look at this
and I think her study really is trying
to get at you know what is possible in
this grand sort of set a set of
initiatives we've been working on for
the health reform under the Accountable
Care Act and other initiatives here in
Oregon oh great and I want to echo
Vishnu thought this was a great
internship we want to thank the National
Library of Medicine and whose sponsors
most of the interns here and certainly
makes this program possible so thanks
hello I'm Katie Cartwright and I'm going
to be talking about the high-value
elements of the patient centered primary
care home so like dr. door said I'm a
senior Oregon State University getting
my bachelor's degree in public health
with an option and health promotion and
health behavior I've got to start
Linfield nursing school and i'm
originally from Seaside Oregon so here's
a quick overview of what I'll be talking
about first I'll be talking about the
patient centered primary care homes
which are a part of the health reform to
improve primary care and patient
outcomes then i'll be talking about top
med which is a trial to evaluate the
patient centered primary care home
effectiveness and how it can be improved
then i'll talk about my focus which are
the high-value elements which are part
of the print
the pc pc age that are said to make the
most improvement and then i'll talk
about my project which was a literature
review on the high-value elements to see
how much change is possible and how they
affect the Triple Aim which are the
three main goals of the pc PCH so the
patient centered primary care home is
oregon's version of the medical home
model um so it looks or it's part of the
health care reform to improve primary
care they focus on the whole picture of
each patient and provide care on the
basis of the patient's individual goals
they focus on they are dedicated to
improving the overall health of their
patients by encouraging preventive
services rather than simply just
treating illness as it appears they work
as a team and coordinate care between
the patient's primary care physician
specialists nurses and pharmacists they
have to meet certain requirements to be
considered a patient centered primary
care home and ensures pay the clinic's
based on how they meet these goals you
have six main components access to care
accountability comprehensive whole
person care continuity coordination and
integration and person and
family-centered care however the medical
home models are very complex and some
have over 100 elements within these six
categories the Triple Aim are the main
three goals population health and
quality metrics patient satisfaction and
cost and utilization which is the main
goal because our healthcare system is so
expensive and by reducing overall cost
we can help lower insurance premiums
there have been several studies on the
effectiveness of the medical home model
some have shown very large savings like
the non randomized trials on large
integrated systems however some have
showed mixed effects like the national
demonstration project out of the trials
that have shown improvements the high
value elements have been derived and are
supposed to demonstrate the most
effective parts of the medical home
model dr. Dorn the team created top med
to test these elements top med stands
for transforming outcomes for patients
through medical home evaluation and
redesign its goal is to improve the
quality of care for seniors and patients
with chronic illnesses it measures the
safety effectiveness and experience of
patients in the medical models such as a
patient centered primary care home top
Matt is a cluster randomized control
trial the control group focuses on all
the components of the PC PCH while the
intervention group focuses on the
high-value elements which were created
for the trial by an advisory committee
based on expert opinion the goals of top
med are the same goals of the PC PCH
however it was created to test if
simplifying the patient-centered primary
care home and focusing on the high value
elements could lead to more success the
high value elements are those attributes
of the patient-centered medical home
practice that will provide the largest
quality to the patients and cost
benefits to the payers they have five
main components identification of
at-risk population care management based
on need patient engagement and proactive
goal-setting integrated information and
procedures across settings and
population management tools
they're derived from the pc PCH
standards but are the ones thought to be
most likely to approve the Triple Aim
however if they actually do improve that
your brain is still unknown so these are
the high-value element standards they
each fit into one of the six pc PCH
components however they are refined to
make them more simpler and measurable
for example one for access is the clinic
being open 12 hours outside of
traditional business hours to reduce
emergency department visits for
continuity they follow up on patient
care after hospitalization or an ED
visits to reduce the amount of patients
being rehospitalizations data to
identify where they can improve for care
coordination they have outreach for
high-risk patients to improve patient
experience and outcomes under person and
family-centered care that provide
written care plans to patients that are
at high risk also to improve patient
experience and outcomes and as a part of
whole person care they send her minors
to preventive care services to improve
population health so for my project I
did a literature review on the high
value elements to find the strength of
these standards so far the high value
elements have been based on expert
opinion so I wanted to see the best
evidence of how much change is possible
and to see if they could lead to success
I found 22 articles and did a data
abstraction and wrote a summary now
we'll give example of a variety of
articles that I found the first is on
after-hours access to care to reduce
emergency department visits it was a
large cohort study that studied actual
after-hours office visit availability
and primary care practices and the rates
of emergency department visits for their
patients it included 57,000 and 850
patients the bottom row of this chart
shows that with 12 hours the relative
rate is point 8 compared to offices with
no evening hours this is a twenty
percent decrease in emergency department
the neck visits at clinics that offered
12 or more hours outside of
tional business hours this shows that
improving access to care during
non-business hours can decrease
unnecessary utilization of services and
reduce costs on the system the next is
on patient specific education resources
and self-management services to improve
patient satisfaction it was a randomized
control trial to explore the impact of
health empowerment intervention on
participation in goal attainment for
homebound older adults this diagram
shows the intervention components there
were 59 participants in this study and
the majority of participants in the
health empowerment intervention group
thought that the sessions were very
helpful to recognize their personal
resources recognize people to turn turn
to for support and progress toward the
attainment of health goals this shows
that health empowerment interventions
including self-management skills can
increase patient satisfaction as well as
their outcomes the next study shows that
sending appropriate preventive care
reminders can improve population health
through increasing screening rates which
will eventually improve patient outcomes
by catching cancers earlier it is on the
effectiveness of using an email system
to send reminders to patients and in
effect to increase colorectal cancer
screening rates it was a randomized
prospective cohort study and involved
two thousand and one hundred patients
the table shows the percentage of
patients that were screened in each
group and that with letter and email
reminders of the percentage of patients
greatly increased these summary tables
show the number of articles that
affected each of the triple aims and the
specific outcome that was affected so
the majority of articles focused on cost
and utilization 5 articles reduced
emergency department visits three
articles found reduced hospitalizations
and five articles found reduced overall
costs for patient satisfaction three
articles improved patient satisfaction
through education and one through
adherence to patient requests and the
last which is population health and
quality measures one article found
reduce mortality three found increased
screening rates and two found Paul
improved quality measures for articles
altogether did not find a significant
difference in the outcome studied but
none of the articles found a negative
impact some limitations were that it was
not a systematic review because not all
the high-value element had randomized
control trials some of the articles use
small sample sizes and some articles had
other factors contributing to the
results but in most cases the high-value
elements did make a significant
difference in at least one of the triple
aims although the level of evidence
berries these studies show that
high-value elements have potential for
success the next step would be to
continue top med and conduct more
controlled randomized trials that could
provide more evidence of the
effectiveness of the high-value elements
and continue to prove patient centered
primary care homes I would like to thank
dr. door in the rest of the team and
also demise in the summer interns thank
you for your presentation could you tell
us a little bit about your search
strategy what terms did you use what
databases did you use how did you
organize the literature that you found
and how did you exclude the ones that
didn't end up making it into the 22 I
use PubMed and since there was 12
high-value elements I found all like to
on most of them and only one on some
because some of them were very difficult
to find a source that was like the had
enough I looked at sample size a lot a
lot of the ones that were for patient
satisfaction had smaller sample sizes
because they were a small group to see
but for the bigger ones like the one on
after-hours access I wanted to make sure
it was you know like a trial with a lot
of participants so some of them were
definitely a challenge and it was took a
lot of searching to find ones that I
thought were legitimate
just as a fall to that we got some data
on nine months of having urgent care
which is in our clinic open after five
o'clock to nine o'clock 195 care
participants care organ participants ed
rate dropped by fifty percent and cost
as well
yeah mentor I'm going to exercise my
right to ask a question um so it's
interesting you sort of describe what
sounds like a pretty eclectic search
strategy sort of looking for each of the
12 high-value elements and seeing what's
out there can you tell us a little bit
about you know were some of the
high-value elements that they have sort
of more of a set of data already
summarized than some last you said the
evidence buried it seemed like you gave
an example of one where it really there
was a model rather than and one where
there was a you know more of a proper
study at least a larger study question
is tell us a little bit about the
variation that you saw amongst the 12
yeah so some were definitely easier to
find and because they've already you
know I think they already people know
that's already important and they're
trying to show that but some like for
care plans there's a lot of different
types of care plans and a lot of came up
were like care plans for kids with
asthma and stuff like that but for the
high-value elements it was more of like
high really high risk patients so that
one was particularly difficult to find
one that focused on all high risk and
then yeah I'd say patient satisfaction
was one of the hardest to to just
because it's you know opinion and but a
lot of them you know if you go an extra
step to help with patient satisfaction
and come up with something to help a lot
of times you know they are going to say
that it was helpful and so those were I
mean there are good studies but it's it
was difficult to find dr. like
scientific basis behind it
while connor is getting what Connors
getting his slides up so Connor Bohannon
from the University of Rochester work
with Judy Logan who has the who
unfortunately is all the way in
Copenhagen so I get to introduce him and
his work with Corey so this is being
recorded so she'll be able to see it get
back to you but I will let him do it
connor Bohan as he said I'm from the
University of Rochester in Rochester New
York and this summer I worked at Corey
Corey is the clinical outcomes research
initiative and what they do is look at
studies and the outcomes of GI
procedures and the chief way in which I
do this is through the quarry software
which is software that allows people who
actually do the procedures to enter in
data about patients that data is then
de-identified so the personal
identifiers are removed from that data
and it's sent to a database and from
there that information can be used in
studies and Corey works with the study
investigators to help them get the data
and then when they're ready to publish
they also work in the publishing so that
that those studies can get submitted
journals and this this is where I'm
specifically working on I'm helping with
the publishing process so the problem
that I'm trying to solve is that there's
currently no real system that they have
for tracking projects that use their
data and tracking the publications and
even just the journal submissions that
aren't publications yet so on the right
side you can see what they currently do
and that's just a website that has a
list of all the publications that use
corey data and problem with this is that
there's it you're required to add
everything manually and it's just a
website and there's no searching
features so it's kind of a bare minimum
and it doesn't have everything you'd
really want so the solution I came up
for this was to create a web based
application and this would allow people
to submit projects into it and journal
submissions and so that core users could
track projects and submissions this is
only available to core
you Corey employees just a matter of
security but there's a it's based on a
database and that database contains
projects and the associated journal
submissions for those projects and
allows the search of that and the
addition and editing of existing
projects and general submissions so the
first feature and the most important
feature of my project was the search
feature this just allows users to search
through the database and you can search
on projects and journal submission
simultaneously and I'll show you how
that works in just a bit and there's a
variety of parameters that were
specified to me that you should be able
to search on and it should be noted that
when searching on multiple parameters
it's more specific so things are
required to adhere to both of your
specifications and not either/or so here
is an example of the search page search
you see is an empty search which means
it returns everything in the database
but you can see the fields on the top
below that you can see two boxes titled
test1 and test2 this is dummy data not
actual projects but those those
represent projects and the italicized
words below those are the investigators
that are responsible for those projects
within each project box you can see
smaller boxes and those are indicative
of journalists submissions for that
project so you might have noticed
they're color-coded black means that the
journal submission is currently pending
approval red means the journal
submission was rejected green means that
the journal submission is accepted and
when on the very bottom one you can see
that it's in full citation format that
means that it's an actual publication
not just a submission to a journal the
second series of features is the adding
and editing features I decided to just
go with the basic route and use a form
field for this
adding and projects is pretty similar
the only difference between added
editing is that there is an ID field at
the top of an editing page and there
isn't one at the top of adding page this
is because each project and submission
has a unique identifier in the database
and this is just used to identify this
so this is a example empty edit project
page so you had a project in the
database it would have a unique
identifier that would go in the quarry
ID slot at the very top I'll show you
how the interface does this for you and
a little bit the rest of the fields are
all the fields that correspond to boxes
in the database and at the very bottom
it has buttons for performing actions
such as saving the changes and deleting
a project from the database so I'm going
to go into a bit of the design
philosophies I used when creating this
application and then give you a little
bit of a tour of the application showing
the the process of adding things to the
database so a few the things I decided I
do is that search would be the basis for
most actions it's just easier that way
if you search first it's the it's the
easiest way to locate something in the
database so I tried to make that the
start for almost any action also because
this application is for a few expert
users I decided to do less hand-holding
and make the interface broader so that
more actions could be completed in fewer
steps another thing I decided to do was
use a technology called ajax ajax is
just a way of making things feel
responsive and not requiring page
refreshes it keeps the application
smoother so I decided I it's a little
bit harder to use but I decided that was
worth it I also tried to use a
consistent look and feel so that means a
single CSS or single style throughout
the whole the whole application and
finally I tried to make sure that every
action had some feedback for that action
so when a user submits something to the
database a little little box pops up on
the bottom of the page and indicates
whether the action was successful or if
it failed for some reason so here's I'm
just going to take you through adding a
project and adding a journal submission
to that project at the very top of the
page is the navigation bar it allows you
to get to any page within the
application in one click so the first
thing you want to do is click the add
project button that will take you to the
ad project dialog page the first two
fields are the title the project and the
principal investigator those are the
only two required fields all the fields
are optional but they include funding
sources and various dates should also be
noted that i tried to use the most
specific type of form entry as possible
so for funding sources there are a
limited number of options and you can
have several of those options so I
decide to use a multi-select it also
notice that if you click a date box it
would pull up a calendar widget which
would automatically format things for
you so that was just another little
design principle I used so after
everything is filled out click the save
project button now when you go into the
search that appears in the database
again an empty search so everything's
returned and then when you want to add a
journal submission to that there's a
little plus icon there's a series of
other icons all the tooltips to explain
what they do the post icon means at
journal submission to this project that
will take you to the journal submission
page it automatically fills out the core
ID for the project that is associated
which with which in this case is 34 and
the rest of the fields just fill in and
then hit save submission and now that
brings you back to the search page
and as you can see the project that
we've created now has an Associated
journal submission which is outlined in
a black box indicating that it's in the
pending stage so it hasn't been accepted
or rejected yeah so I'd like to thank my
mentor dr. guti Logan person I worked
with and designing this is Luke I didn't
have time to add this in but Chris
helped looked over my my presentation
gave me some suggestions I'd like to
recommend thank the rest of the quarry
team and the team ice internship program
are there any questions so I'll go um so
I'd like to know more about who uses the
quarry data and how does corey get
information about their projects and
publications um so that would really be
a best question for Luke since this is
the area he he kind of works in he's the
one who would be using this and I'm not
quite sure how he gets his information
but he does work with people who are
publishing the studies and so he would
he'd be the one using this interface for
the most part
okay thank you